[Música]
o ato de pessoal daqui que falou dar
tudo muito bem vindo é que a minha casa
nova como podem ver produtivo finalmente
conseguiu arranjar um novo espaço para
trabalhos mais viris ri para viver e
isso não é uma casa normal só tem uma
casa de luxo casa luxo agora scoular
duro perder 0 1 mês filho vamos fazer
aqui uma altura vamos mostrar a casa o
quarto gervinho todos os quartos
alugados por que não viver com mais
pessoas do viver com o caso o ano com
brigas com o mais tempo no mundo é com o
windows não é muito justo barak e com
ronaldo para dar meu vocês vão adorar
ser mesmo já tô aqui com alguns
companheiros da casa saiu antes da globo
em longas como a de que a altura é
totalmente o botão muito importante nós
nossos vez mais o dito por não estar
meio betão dois núcleos 3 dia 8
vamos mandar um show meu nós vamos lá
dar um espetáculo muito bom importantes
link da inscrição passa lá concluiu
possibilita pressão provavelmente muito
de você e 22 de agosto
a unila e esse pessoal que atravessam e
atenção importante os bilhetes estão
quatro acabaram por também acompanha bom
agora vamos falar aqui um pouco mais
calma basicamente isso só mostra com
prova de que esta casa deve estar nesta
casa tudo junto e pode levar muitos
vídeos me bateu muito longo quanto o
fundo perto do colégio inglês mil
por isso só vamos tentar chegar aqui a
meta dos 100 mil likes e eu já mostrei
que tenho e fora meu é muito lindo mas
desde já deixo ao vosso aip e bola pra
casa agora
[Música]
e aqui está nosso saldo atual de vans ou
o tamanho meu é muito grande muito
grande primeiro tempo de salvar exonere
distinção contact média então eu conduzo
tem que mostrar tudo que envolva de ser
vítima de uma câmera de segurança
assim ninguém hoje que entrar e fazer
uma porta e temos aqui uma casa ganhou a
[Música]
esta é a cozinha também este um
americano é muito difícil porque ela tem
uma bancada em é outro o que gosto mais
deste kit é composto só por estar aqui e
ver o seu café e ter o pessoal da
cozinha enquanto o sollus em aqui nós
identificarmos a quinta com gustavo
sabino nosso dever é muito linda me
bater disse que no momento meu tá muito
igual está muito igual mesmo esperar
esse mesmo lembrou que não é um caneco e
aproveitei muito prático é o pessoal
essa é a parte exterior é onde eu tenho
piscina eo jardim venceu é muito bem
aqui fora tá cheio naturezas manhã é
muito bom de ver o sol de bananeira meu
muito bom eu curto a casa toda mesmo
quanto muito a casa do eu vou mostrar ó
[Música]
aqui tem também uma rede de vôlei bola
que dá pra fazer muitas coisas com bola
e tem inclusive um imenso off é muito
grande
eu acho que já mostrei meu parque do
jardim a parte mais importante na queda
na bolsa também muito logo agora quando
o processo andar e vamos lá ver o
esporte em cima aí que tive aqui embaixo
tem outros quatro que é o dono mora o
pib pelo vamos agora para a drenagem é o
nós temos das máquinas de defesa civil
agora sim damos ao segundo andar para lá
o primeiro poeta que descuidar do caso
joaquim adir é que vamos lá ver como é
que eu só compro primeiro quarto não
agora
[Música]
qualquer só estamos agora mais
privacidade aqui no meu quarto eu curto
muito este 40 nos preocupa é só
felicidade
qualquer fator de penteado neste momento
mas não entrega podem vir 14 também é
muito iluminado eu tenho aqui é minha
cama gigantesca mas quem sabe eu tenho
que estar maria também tem aqui coisas
venda uma câmera de vigilância melhorar
algumas facas governo escuta o escudo
caso urgente acordos podem oferecer
algumas fotos fazer um vídeo só do pt
está necessário alguém aqui está o meu
pai mas muito bom mas não viram
breakbeat bastou perder a melhor coisa
da nossa vida porque eu sou mais você
usar suas 50 são muito bons mesmo com
ela disse que eu era um cheiro cor e
aqui eu não percebo a novabase pelas
matas parcelar os 20 também pessoal
próprio e vocês coisas básicas têm como
destino o ps é que tem o meu meet greet
em sua comida saudável agora é melhores
parte deste quarto dentro do meu quarto
eu tenho um filósofo que é um cofre é
basicamente um armário mas que é quase
uma divisão onde estão isto tudo é um
armário dentro do meu eu nunca tinha
visto em casa é muito bom tem muitas
cabeças muito escassos muita coisa que
eu gosto daqui
danny que o bce indica que roupa muita
coisa e ainda a emoção até aí eu vi que
a equipe só os carros à nossa casa do
bairro brutal vazou muito irmã eu nunca
pensei que eu ia tomar banho quando este
mês ao meu lado
olha só o meu quarto é brutal lendo
super prefeito
temos mais uma coisa pra complementar
que é a nossa varanda
vamos ver a melhor vista de sempre
embora
[Música]
ah
vamos a uma nova meta nós conseguiram
atingir os 200 mil likes eu vou saltar
da minha varanda para a china ela
provasse rock 200 mil e os assuntos do
senado e agora no windows e no quarto do
antes que é o maior quarto para a ilha
grande não conhecia ainda qual vai
alguém lá em cima ainda não há meta
vamos tentar aqui com seu pagamento para
o painel e não tem imensos cabo e vai
ter muito confuso dandara ligado nas
portas teto nem lei passada e eu já vou
aproveitar para um solitário um
pouquinho com elas pois eu vou deixar
este vídeo postado há dúvida que eu
sempre quis ter que ter uma qualidade de
vida boa temos menos tempo à minha volta
e está a fazer o que eu gosto que está a
trabalhar em casa teve gente só quando
eu comecei a fazer deixaram da casa já
sabem que vocês também vão ter mais
vídeos que provavelmente não irão viajar
porque não posso perder muito tempo né e
aqui vocês podem se inscrever porque era
uma coisa que vai até a próxima